and who else Davy Crockett that bad
buoyant dude you try to [ __ ] fight
somebody in a Coonskin cap and win
Kim dude first of all they had one dude
used to sell raccoon penis uh necklaces
and they would beat his ass all the time
bro
can you imagine some dude shows up in a
[ __ ] octopus swim cap saying he's
gonna defend the land somebody gonna
whoop his ass
so Davy Crockett doesn't get enough cry
caught it because Davy Crockett was an
American super human the may think about
[ __ ] defending something while you
wearing a [ __ ] ostrich one-piece bra
somebody's gonna kick your ass do you
think about somebody comes in you're
working at a 7-eleven right you're
working at a 7-eleven and somebody comes
in and holds a gun and you got a [ __ ]
eel you know you got a eel skin eye
patch on they're gonna [ __ ] shoot you
man but Davy Crockett wore the shadiest
[ __ ] you could wear a raccoon skin cap
imagine taking a cap off of an animal
that plays in the garbage and defending
your nation with it or defending your
land or whatever he defended I think he
defended like a um I don't know what
even what it was like he might have done
a drive-by shooting I don't know what
Davy Crockett did okay because the
government is taking away some of the
books but I do know that to successfully
defend something while you're wearing
something that everybody wants to kill
you for wearing because it looks
ridiculous hard to do you know imagine I
got along I got on a Chelsea Handler you
know me I got a jump suit made out of
Chelsea Handler's skin
scales and I'm gonna defend the do the
second I walk out into the mainstream
with that pop pop somebody gonna you
know put me in that hard scarf baby and
choke me out so the fact that Davy
Crockett did that highly unrecognized as
a hero highly unrecognized evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better what if you
watch a video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one